[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich habe mir überlegt, euch zu zeigen,
wie ich eine Schmuckaufbewahrung bastle,
weil ich einfach generell das Problem habe
– ich habe jetzt nicht so viel Schmuck,
aber ich habe immer das Problem,
die Ketten verheddern sich.
Die hängen bei mir momentan im Bad über so einem Türknauf.
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
das Ganze kann man doch ziemlich stylisch machen.
Und dann hatte ich leider ein paar Ideen zu viel.
Ich glaube, das Video artet ein bisschen aus.
Und ich zeige euch jetzt, wie ich hier hinter mir diese Ecke
– ich habe da nämlich so eine Kommode stehen –
und wie ich diese Ecke jetzt verschönere.
Und vielleicht habt ihr Lust,
das Ganze mitzuverfolgen.
Ich habe jetzt hier schon mal so einen Sessel geholt,
der mir einfach farblich super gefällt.
Ich werde jetzt noch Farbe aussuchen für die Wand,
weil ich glaube, ich werde die Wand auch noch mitstreichen.
Dann machen wir ein bisschen
Schmuckaufbewahrung für die Wände,
für den Tisch.
Und ihr könnt bestimmt für euer Zimmer,
für euer Bad, Kinderzimmer, Schlafzimmer,
einfach auch was mitnehmen und
gucken, wie ihr vielleicht den Schmuck
zu Hause aufbewahren könnt
und wie ihr so ein paar Dekoideen abholen könnt.
Also
werde ich jetzt erst mal eine Farbe aussuchen
und dann Murat schnell zum Baumarkt schicken.
Und ich fange dann schon in der Werkstatt an.
[Musik]
Ich wollte eigentlich voll das schöne Puderrosa
und der sah dort auch echt puderrosa aus.
>> JOSH: Er ist braun.
>> SALLY: Ja!
Das weiß ich jetzt auch.
Aber ich werde ihn trotzdem puderrosa machen.
Ist mir egal.
[Musik]
Eigentlich wollte ich ja, dass es in die Richtung geht.
>> JOSH: Und jetzt?
>> SALLY: Aber der Sessel ist so.
Was jetzt, Josh?
>> JOSH: Wir machen einfach eine Farbpalette draus.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob mir die nicht zu dunkel wird.
Ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, okay, ich mache es so.
Ich nehme
Hibiskus 3.
Oder Hibiskus 2?
Wer die Wahl hat...
Ich nehme Hibiskus 3.
Okay, Hibiskus 3 nehmen wir.
[Musik]
Also momentan habe ich alle meine Sachen
– okay, nicht alle, aber einige –
hier drin.
Den Schmuckständer hier
habe ich eigentlich mal für Samira gekauft für ihr Zimmer
und habe ihn dann einfach kurzerhand für mich benutzt.
Aber die kriegt ihn jetzt wieder zurück.
Und wie gesagt, hier hat man einfach so die Ketten.
Die kann man schon schön aufhängen,
aber ich habe zum Beispiel für meine Armreifen,
für meine Ohrstecker, die ich halt vermehrt trage,
einfach keinen Platz.
Und deswegen gehen wir jetzt in die Werkstatt
und werden jetzt
Schmuckaufbewahrungsdinge
bauen.
Okay, du siehst mich immer noch.
Also ich muss sagen, die Idee zur Kettenaufbewahrung,
die habe ich auf Pinterest gesehen.
Da kann man sich nämlich aus dem Ausland irgendwo
so eine Kettenaufbewahrung bestellen aus Holz.
Und ich habe mir gedacht:
"Nee, komm. Die können wir auch selber machen."
Und zwar haben wir bei uns hier in der Garage
immer ganz viel Restholz,
so ein bisschen Sperrholz.
Man kann sich aber auch einfach beim Baumarkt was kaufen
und sogar zusägen lassen.
Also ihr müsstet theoretisch nicht mal selber sägen,
sondern ihr könnt zum Baumarkt gehen
und einfach die Maße durchgeben.
Ich denke, ich werde jetzt von den Maßen her
eher etwas Längliches brauchen,
so wie hier ungefähr.
Nicht ganz so hoch, weil das wäre mir jetzt schon zu sperrig.
Aber ich kann
ungefähr sagen:
Also von der Breite her
würde ich schon auf etwa 10, 11 cm gehen
und von der Länge her ungefähr auf 30 cm.
Das Ganze braucht jetzt natürlich noch einen Fuß.
Ihr könnt euch das jetzt hier so vorstellen.
Das liegt ja später so hochkant,
ist so leicht angeschrägt, damit die Ketten schön drauf liegen,
und ich mache hier so Einkerbungen rein,
damit ich die Kette einzeln hinhängen kann.
Und so verheddern sie später auch nicht mehr
und ihr habt sie einfach schön übersichtlich.
Und jetzt brauche ich dafür einen Fuß.
Den kann ich aus Holz machen
oder aus Beton.
Und so werde ich es später machen.
Und, damit ich später einfach auch eine Form habe
für den Betonfuß,
werde ich mir gleich eine Form zurechtschneiden.
Aber jetzt geht es erst mal ans Holz.
Und da schneide ich mir jetzt gleich das Maß zu
und zeichne es an.
Aber, wie gesagt, ihr könnt es auch zuschneiden lassen.
Ist ein bisschen einfacher.
Also das Brett hat jetzt hier so knapp 18 cm,
so knapp unter 18 cm.
Ich werde es jetzt einfach halbieren,
das heißt ungefähr 8,75 cm.
Und da könnt ihr das so machen:
Ihr nehmt so eine Klammer,
packt sie hier an euer Maß,
was ihr haben möchtet.
Und dann könnt ihr das nämlich
mit einer Bewegung direkt machen.
Hier ansetzen
Bleistift dran
und dann entlangziehen.
[Musik]
Okay.
Gut.
Dann lege ich das jetzt kurz zur Seite.
Das ist praktisch meine Kettenaufbewahrung.
Und jetzt mache ich noch eine Aufbewahrung für
Armketten, Uhren,
Armreifen.
Und dafür habe ich jetzt hier Rundholz
in verschiedenen Stärken.
Und das könnt ihr euch jetzt so vorstellen,
dass ich in der Mitte so einen Mast habe
und dann hier so kleine Querstreben.
Und da kann man dann alles schön aufbewahren.
Und da macht ihr es am besten so:
Ihr zeichnet euch so ungefähr auf, wie ihr es haben wollt.
Da gucke ich, muss ich tatsächlich sagen,
auch wieder auf Pinterest so ein bisschen nach Ideen.
Aber ich schreibe euch dann die Maße,
die ich genommen habe, auf jeden Fall ganz exakt rein.
Da kann man sich dann überlegen,
ob man eben einen Querbalken macht oder mehrere
oder die sogar versetzt macht.
[Musik]
Für den mittleren Masten nehme ich jetzt
hier dieses Rundholz mit 1,5 cm Durchmesser
und für die Querstreben hier mit 3,5 cm.
Und ihr guckt einfach selber,
wie hoch und groß ihr das haben wollt,
wie viele Querstreben drin sein sollen.
Ich mache jetzt zwei,
habe ich jetzt mal so vor,
und schreibe euch dann
auch die genauen Maße natürlich alle hin.
Und das schneide ich jetzt auch vorne kurz zu.
Ich benutze jetzt einfach meine Tischkreissäge
zum Abschneiden.
Ganz wichtig: Einfach immer geschlossene Haare
und einfach die Arbeitssicherheit immer beachten.
[Musik]
Um mein Holzbrett jetzt zu halbieren,
nehme ich jetzt hier den Parallelanschlag,
damit wirklich alles sauber abgeschnitten wird,
und einfach zur Sicherheit noch hier die Abdeckung
und einen Schiebestock zum Schutze meiner Finger.
[Musik]
Perfekt halbiert!
Und jetzt zeichne ich mir hier am Rand
noch die Einkerbungen an.
Und ich denke, ich werde sie so im 3-cm-Abstand machen.
Nach unten hin dann keine mehr,
denn da kommt ja noch der Betonfuß.
Und dann kann ich hier
schon bestimmt sechs bis sieben Ketten aufhängen.
Also hier im 3-cm-Abstand
schön am Rand auf beiden Seiten anzeichnen.
[Musik]
Und die Einkerbungen hier,
die müssen natürlich nach unten gehen,
damit die Kette hier schön drin hängen kann.
Wenn ihr eine Tischkreissäge habt, klappt das echt ganz gut.
Ansonsten zeige ich euch jetzt eine Alternative.
Ich zeige euch das mal hier an meinem Reststück,
wie ich das jetzt mit der Handsäge machen würde.
Ein Geodreieck habe ich jetzt nicht.
Aber ich zeichne es euch so mal kurz an.
Also, wenn ihr kein Geodreieck habt,
nehmt ihr einfach euren Zollstock.
Einmal hier anzeichnen.
Das wäre so die Tiefe.
Und dann würde ich hier anfangen,
hier oben die 3 cm mir markieren.
Drei, sechs...
Und dann
etwas mit Versatz nach unten
drei
– ups!
[Musik]
Und dann muss man es ja nur noch verbinden.
Dann habt ihr hier auch immer schön den gleichen Winkel.
Und jetzt bohrt ihr hier in der Mitte ein Loch.
Dann habt ihr nämlich schon mal
eine schöne Rundung hier in der Mitte.
Und entweder nehmt ihr jetzt einen Schraubendreher
oder so eine Anreißhilfe,
markiert einmal hier
das Loch.
Das hat dann den Vorteil,
dass der Bohrer gleich nicht verrutscht.
[Musik]
Und ich nehme jetzt hier einfach so einen 6-mm-Bohrer,
bohre hier ein Loch.
Und immer einen Untergrund nehmen,
also in ein anderes Holz reinbohren, damit es nicht ausreißt.
Und ihr seht schon, dass der Bohrer
wirklich einen schönen Halt hat.
[Musik]
Und dann klemme ich mir das jetzt hierein.
Wenn ihr das nicht habt, braucht ihr einfach
zwei Hände.
Und im Prinzip tut es da eigentlich jede Säge.
Ich muss dazusagen,
die hat, glaube ich, jeder zu Hause,
weil die in jedem Bauset mit dabei ist.
Und für mich ist das jetzt auch so persönlich die Handlichste.
Und dann einfach
hier zweimal sägen, sodass ihr praktisch
einmal rechts und links vom Loch entlang sägt.
[Musik]
Ist nicht ganz die eleganteste Lösung.
Funktioniert,
aber ich mache meine Schmuckaufbewahrung
jetzt an der Tischkreissäge.
Mit der Höhe des Sägeblattes
bestimmt man jetzt praktisch die Tiefe des Schnitts.
Ich habe das Ganze jetzt schräg angestellt
und kann jetzt hier einfach schön reinschneiden,
ohne dass ich das Geodreieck brauche,
und ich habe einfach perfekte Schnitte.
Lasst euch nicht stören vom Papa.
Der muss hier wieder wild mitarbeiten.
Also, was ihr machen müsst, ist,
hier die Zwischenräume auf jeden Fall schleifen.
Gell, Papa?
>> SALLYS PAPA: Was?
>> SALLY: Immer schön abschleifen.
>> SALLYS PAPA: Ja.
Yer no pas tamam yapsın tamirat.
>> SALLY: Hm. Yapıştıracağım zaten. Genau.
>> SALLYS PAPA: Olsun mıdır.
>> SALLY: Perfekt! Danke!
Ja, wir haben gerade festgestellt, der Papa und ich,
wir haben keinen 14-mm-Bohrer
für die runde Variante hier.
Also nehme ich jetzt doch 10 mm,
so ein 10-mm-Rundholz.
Das passt auch.
Aber, wie gesagt, hier erst mal abschleifen,
einmal die Zwischenräume.
Da könnt ihr das Schleifpapier einfach so umknicken,
damit ihr beide Seiten habt.
Dann könnt ihr gern einmal noch mal über die Oberfläche
entweder auch mit dem Schleifpapier
oder mit so einem Exzenterschleifer.
Geht halt einfach und schneller.
[Musik]
Und es hat auch den Vorteil,
dass ich teilweise noch Flecken wegbekomme,
wenn das Holz nicht mehr so ganz schön ist.
[Musik]
So. Das Holz ist jetzt perfekt vorbereitet.
Das Einzige, was mir nicht gefällt, ist die Farbe.
Deswegen beize ich das Holz jetzt noch.
Ich habe jetzt hier so eine wasserlösliche Pulverbeize.
Und die mische ich mir jetzt einmal mit heißem Wasser.
Das ist jetzt die Farbe
Nussbaum dunkel.
Denn ich hätte es einfach gern ein bisschen dunkel.
Und dann kann ich das hier jetzt einmal ausprobieren.
Ui! Sehr dunkel.
Uh!
Aber ich finde es richtig schön.
So mache ich es.
Ich nehme jetzt die Handschuhe.
Einweg habe ich jetzt nicht gefunden,
aber die lasse ich einfach in der Werkstatt,
meine Werkstatthandschuhe.
Und jetzt einfach schön das Holz beizen.
Ich finde, das sieht jetzt dadurch sofort viel edler aus.
[Musik]
Richtig genial.
Hier noch die Zwischenräume nicht vergessen.
[Musik]
Schön!
Die Holzbretter lasse ich jetzt kurz trocknen.
Jetzt habe ich hier mein Rundholz.
Die habe ich ja bereits zugeschnitten
für die Armketten und Armreifen.
Und da werde ich mir jetzt einfach
in der Mitte den Punkt markieren
und werde dann einfach ein Loch durchbohren,
damit das Rundholz durchpasst.
Also einfach bei allen hier einmal die Mitte markieren.
[Musik]
Das nächste Mal mache ich eine gerade Zahl.
Jedes Mal muss ich Komma fünf rechnen,
33 durch 2.
[Musik]
Im besten Falle läuft es jetzt so ab,
dass das Ganze hier reinpasst
und sogar so schön eng ist,
dass man es nicht leimen muss.
Passt.
Muss man nicht leimen.
So.
Da oben drübergeschliffen
sieht man jetzt auch keinen Übergang mehr.
Und dann wird das jetzt schön einbetoniert.
Das habe ich jetzt vorbereitet,
werde es aber jetzt noch vorher kurz beizen,
dass das auch farblich wieder dazu passt.
Daher auch meine Werkstattschürze
und Handschuhe.
[Musik]
Mein Papa kam eben und hat gesagt:
"Şu uzun olanı yollar",
also "Schick mal den langen Jungen mit."
Dann gucke ich so Josh und Max an,
so: Beide lang.
"Okay. Max, geh mal mit meinem Vater raus."
Und dann sagt der Papa: "Nein, nein, der andere Lange."
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Papa,
ich brauche den Josh zum Filmen."
Und danach kam...
Und dann kam der Murat.
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Nimm den Murat mit."
Da sagt er, nee, den Kurzen braucht er nicht.
Ach Papa.
[Musik]
So. Dann habe ich jetzt erst mal alles gebeizt.
Und sobald die Beize trocken ist,
was es jetzt bei den flachen Hölzern schon ist,
kann ich das Ganze versiegeln.
Das ist ja jetzt wie Wasserfarbe und auch wasserlöslich.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt wirklich Wasser drauf tropfen würde,
würde es halt auch wieder abgehen.
Also hier noch einen Versiegelungslack.
Und ich habe jetzt hier einen matten.
Denn ich will es ja auch schön matt belassen.
Das in gut durchleucht-
– gut durchlüfteten Räumen oder draußen machen.
Jetzt ist hier alles schön getrocknet und versiegelt.
Und damit die Ketten da später schön dran hängen können
und nicht runterrutschen auch von der Länge her,
möchte ich hier hinten noch Nägel dran machen.
Das heißt, ihr sucht euch jetzt die Vorderseite.
Die habe ich.
Die drehe ich jetzt weg.
Dann einmal die Mitte markieren.
[Musik]
Und jetzt am besten vom ersten Punkt hier versetzt
weiter unten anfangen.
Also das könnt ihr entweder kurz ausmessen
oder den ersten Punkt einfach mal festlegen.
Und dann eben wieder in 3-cm-Schritten.
Und ich nehme jetzt hier einfach
schöne Nägel mit so einem größeren Kopf
und schlage die jetzt aber so ein bisschen schräg ein,
sodass die Kette da auch wirklich einfach dran hängen kann.
Nicht zu weit durchschlagen natürlich.
>> JOSH: Hör mal, wer da hämmert.
>> SALLY: Hör mal, wer da hämmert!
[Musik]
Ich glaube, ein ein bisschen kleinerer Nagel
hätte es auch getan.
Ah!
>> JOSH: Sorry!
>> SALLY: Au!
Voll auf den Daumen!
Ich sage es dir, wenn der morgen blau ist, dann
mache ich auch blau.
[Musik]
Bevor jetzt betoniert wird,
wirklich alles schön bereitlegen.
Das heißt, ich habe hier meine Rundhölzer,
die Kettenaufbewahrung,
ich habe meine Formen.
Zwei eckige hierfür.
Dann zwei runde.
Da nehme ich den größeren hier
und den kleineren hier.
Ich habe noch kleine Hölzer.
Die brauche ich gleich.
Und da wirklich alles schön bereitlegen,
damit die Betonmasse gleich nicht zu schnell fest wird
und ihr wirklich gut alles aufarbeiten könnt.
Dann ein bisschen Draht.
So.
Und der ist für die Stabilität da.
Also den könnt ihr euch so ein bisschen zurechtbiegen,
so, wie die Form eben auch ist.
Und der hält den Beton dann gut in Form
und stabilisiert das Ganze eben.
Aufpassen, dass er nicht am Rand rausguckt,
also klein genug machen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt kann ich hier
die Glasur anmischen.
Josh sagt, das machen wir jetzt nach Gefühl,
also machen wir es nach Gefühl.
>> JOSH: Ja, es kommt ja drauf an,
was für eine Konsistenz du haben willst.
>> SALLY: Eben.
Und ich brauche jetzt, würde ich sagen,
eine gute, feste Rührteigkonsistenz.
Jetzt hier schön mit der Küchenmaschine.
Lieber mal etwas weniger.
Also
dann geht es los.
Schön klopfen, damit sich es verteilt.
Und hier auch die Reste
so ein bisschen mit dem Teigschaber wegnehmen.
Dann kommt jetzt hier Part eins rein.
[Musik]
Jetzt gibt es noch ein paar Ohrstecker-
und Ohrringaufbewahrungen.
Und dafür nehme ich ganz normale Bilderrahmen.
Die gibt es auch in verschiedenen Größen.
und verschiedene Materialien.
Hier habe ich jetzt die Rückwand rausgelöst.
Zum einen möchte ich jetzt
eine Aufbewahrung aus Kork machen.
Also habe ich hier auf der Rolle einfach gekauft.
Es gibt aber auch schon solche Korkplatten,
sogar mit selbsthaftender Rückseite.
Und die sind auch schon in einer schönen Form.
Also so könnte man das Ganze auch gestalten.
und kann ja auch zum Beispiel
diese Form dann übertragen auf Spiegel zum Beispiel.
Ich nehme jetzt allerdings die Rolle.
Und ich denke, dass das dann eine schöne Aufbewahrung
gerade für so Ohrstecker zum Beispiel ist.
Das heißt, ich messe mir jetzt einfach hier innen
den Bilderrahmen aus und schneide dann
die Korkplatte dementsprechend zu.
Ich habe hier 11,5 cm
mal 16,5 cm.
[Musik]
Also ich habe das Ganze jetzt so ein bisschen geglättet
und klebe das jetzt hier rein
mit doppelseitigem Klebeband.
[Musik]
Jetzt setze ich erst mal das wieder ein
und jetzt die Korkplatte.
[Musik]
So.
Und ich glaube,
ich werde das nicht mal hinhängen,
sondern vielleicht hinstellen.
Also ich lasse mir mal die Option offen.
Falls ich es doch hinhängen möchte,
kann ich hier hinten immer noch
was anschrauben zum An-die-Wand-Hängen.
Aber ich lasse es jetzt erst mal so.
[Musik]
Das ist ganz cool.
Also ich finde, das ist ein bisschen locker geworden.
Hier ist es auch ein bisschen eingerissen.
Ich frage mal gleich
Volkan, den Betonexperten,
ob ich vielleicht was falsch gemacht habe.
>> VOLKAN: Das Problem ist,
das ist so eine Flüssigkeit manchmal.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> VOLKAN: Wenn das so eine Flüssigkeit ist,
cracken die, oder wenn es nicht genug Sand ist
oder ein bisschen Stein.
Wir müssen immer die Steine und den Sand
– Sand in guter Proportion reinmachen.
>> SALLY: Ah, okay.
>> VOLKAN: Zum Beispiel ist es dreimal Sand
und einmal Beton.
>> SALLY: Ah. Aber ich hatte extra so eine Fertigmischung.
>> VOLKAN: Ja, die Fertigmischung...
>> SALLY: Ist nicht gut?
>> VOLKAN: Mhm, das ist nicht gut.
>> SALLY: Machst du Beton immer selber?
>> VOLKAN: Immer selber.
>> SALLY: Mh.
>> VOLKAN: Immer guter Beton und guter Sand
und eine gute Mischung und nicht so eine Flüssigkeit.
[Musik]
Ja, ja, ja.
>> SALLY: Dann klebe ich das jetzt einfach rein.
>> VOLKAN: Ja.
>> SALLY: Danke, Volkan.
>> VOLKAN: Sehr gerne!
Tschau!
>> SALLY: Also das nächste Mal mischen wir Beton selber an
und dann machen wir mit Volkan
mal so einen Beton-Workshop,
dass so was nicht mehr passiert.
Jetzt zeige ich euch, wie ihr aus Bilderrahmen
eine tolle Ohrringaufbewahrung machen könnt.
Also ich habe jetzt hier nur den Rahmen.
Den Hintergrund brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe hier einen festen Jutestoff.
Den gibt es im Bastelladen.
Also das ist der, den man eben auch zum Sticken benutzt.
Und das schneide ich jetzt eben in der Größe zu.
Ein bisschen kleiner darf es ruhig sein.
Und dann tackere ich das Ganze hier an den inneren Rand,
also nicht hier hinten drauf.
Denn, wenn ihr es hinhängt an die Wand,
dann ist ja das direkt press an der Wand
und dann könnt ihr keine Ohrringe drüberhängen.
Also wirklich an den inneren Rand.
Jetzt am besten schon mal so eine Knickfalte machen.
Dann legt sich es gut rein.
Und dann am besten aufrecht hinstellen
und mit dem Tacker
hier direkt reintackern.
Schön auf Spannung,
also erst mal die eine Seite und dann die gegenüberliegende.
[Musik]
Perfekt, würde ich sagen. Sieht echt gut aus.
Und das Ganze kann man jetzt
mit so schlichten Rahmen machen
oder mit so Barockrahmen.
Die könnt ihr vorher sogar noch ein bisschen ansprühen,
wenn euch die Farbe nicht gefällt.
Und je nachdem, was für einen Stil ihr habt,
passt der eine oder der andere Rahmen
eben ganz gut bei euch rein.
Und wenn ihr es hinstellen wollt,
solltet ihr die Rückwand noch mal benutzen.
Falls ihr es hinhängen wollt,
einfach hier hinten was zum Aufhängen hinmachen,
falls eben nichts da ist.
Ich habe jetzt hier auch meine Töpfe noch angesprüht.
Denn da möchte ich meine kleinen Kakteen reinpflanzen.
Deswegen auch Handschuhe,
denn ich hatte neulich schon
– Kaktusspitzen? Nadeln?
Wie heißen die? Dornen?
Ja, jetzt komm, Sarah. Komm, komm! Botanikexpertin.
Kakteendornen in der Hand
und es war echt sehr schmerzhaft.
Und beim Einpflanzen muss man beachten:
Entweder setzt man sie mit so einem Innentöpfchen rein,
sodass einfach das Wasser abfließen kann,
oder man nimmt
hier diese,
diesen Blähton.
Also ich will das jetzt ohne Innentopf,
weil es ist halt schöner.
Ich hoffe, sie überleben es.
Und jetzt habe ich hier sogar Spezialkakteenerde.
[Musik]
Guckt mal, wie schön das jetzt hier schon aussieht,
was so ein Topf einfach ausmacht
in der richtigen Farbe.
[Musik]
Gut!
Dann haben wir das jetzt auch erledigt.
Jetzt zeige ich euch noch eine schöne Aufbewahrung.
Und zwar gibt es hier diese Schmuckdosen.
Da kann man ganz toll Ohrstecker
oder zum Beispiel auch Ringe drin verstauen.
Und wenn ihr so was nicht findet oder nicht habt
und sagt: "Ich habe eine Lieblingsbox,
da möchte ich es gerne reinmachen",
könnt ihr euch einfach eine leere Box nehmen.
Es kann auch zum Beispiel eine Süßigkeitenschachtel sein.
Da gibt es ja mittlerweile auch echt ganz tolle Verpackungen,
die man einfach aufheben kann
und eben ganz toll verwerten kann.
Und dafür braucht ihr einfach ein bisschen Filz,
also Bastelfilz aus dem Bastelladen.
Die Breite sollte dann
so sein wie hier,
also wie die Aufbewahrung.
Bei mir passt es sogar schon fast.
Ich muss es nur minimal zuschneiden.
Und dann braucht ihr entweder Rundholz oder alte Stifte
oder zum Beispiel Strohhalme.
Die braucht ihr nämlich für innen rein zum Rollen.
Und ich zeige euch jetzt, wie das funktioniert.
Ich messe jetzt hier die Breite meiner Box aus,
– das sind jetzt hier 19 cm –
übertrage es auf meinen Filz.
[Musik]
Den Stift oder das Holz schneidet ihr ein bisschen kleiner zu.
Dann geht es einfacher rein in die Box.
[Musik]
Und dann klebe ich das Ganze jetzt mit Heißkleber an
und wickle den Stift ein.
[Musik]
Und je nachdem, wie dicke die Rolle sein soll,
so lange oder so kurz muss eben auch das Vlies sein.
Ich probiere es jetzt mal einmal im Kompletten,
ob es zu dick ist.
Aber
ich finde, es passt.
[Musik]
Also, da mir jetzt hier vier Stück gut gefallen,
klebe ich jetzt auch das Ende schon mal zu,
damit sich es nicht wieder aufrollt.
[Musik]
Ah, das muss ich jetzt aber mal testen direkt.
Oh!
Das sieht viel schöner aus
und viel hochwertiger als dieses Billigding!
Nicht?
Ist schon so.
Für Ohrstecker und Ringe aller Art.
Das letzte Mal habe ich jetzt einfach aufgehört,
weil ich keine Wasserwaage hatte.
Jetzt habe ich endlich eine.
Also ich zeichne jetzt hier
einmal mein Rechteck vor
und klebe es dann gleich ab.
Und mit der Wasserwaage
funktioniert es wirklich am allerbesten.
[Musik]
Fertig angezeichnet.
Jetzt nehme ich ein bisschen Klebeband zum Abkleben
und klebe es so ab, dass ich immer so minimal
außerhalb der Linie bleibe,
damit die Linie im Innern bleibt
und ich die eben später überpinseln kann.
Dann sieht man den Bleistift nämlich nicht mehr.
[Musik]
Dann hier innen schön andrücken.
Da verschmiert der Bleistift jetzt ein bisschen,
aber ist nicht schlimm.
Es ist ja nur auf dem Klebeband.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch ein breiteres benutzen.
Aber, falls ihr auch nur so ein schmales habt,
einfach doppelt kleben.
Dann habt ihr keine Gefahr,
dass ihr aus Versehen rausmalt.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich die weiße Wandfarbe,
die ich auch als Untergrund habe,
und kann jetzt mit einem Pinsel
hier den Übergang versiegeln.
Das heißt, hin zum Klebeband streichen,
damit später die bunte Farbe,
die ich dann an die Wand mache,
eben nicht nach außen dringt.
Und so habt ihr dann einen schönen, glatten Übergang.
[Musik]
Das ist jetzt so wie bei Fondanttorten.
Die erste Schicht, die Krümelschicht, die stopft die Löcher
und sorgt dafür, dass später die obere Schicht,
also der Fondant, die bunte Farbe, eben glatt aufliegt.
Und wenn ihr das jetzt nicht sauber macht,
dann habt ihr später auch kein sauberes Ergebnis.
Also nehmt euch dafür kurz Zeit.
[Musik]
Also Schritt eins ist jetzt schon mal erledigt.
Die Farbe muss ich jetzt natürlich antrocknen lassen.
In der Zwischenzeit gönnen wir uns einen leckeren Smoothie.
Und dann geht es gleich weiter.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist hier alles getrocknet.
Eine Farbprobe habe ich hier auch schon mal gemacht.
Es ist ein bisschen zu rosa,
aber ich glaube, am Ende passt es.
Und jetzt rolle ich hier die Fläche kurz.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach eine kleine Rolle,
weil ich so einen Minieimer habe,
so einen minikleinen gemischten Eimer.
So.
Ah, doch, es ist doch eine schöne Farbe.
Es ist ja auch mein Mädchenzimmer.
Jetzt kommt wieder die Gender-Diskussion:
"Warum Mädchen? Warum Rosa?"
Weil ich ein Mädchen bin und Rosa mag.
Und ich arbeite jetzt immer erst mal am Rand entlang,
damit ich nicht aus Versehen drübermale.
Das kann nämlich schnell bei mir passieren,
wenn ich abgelenkt bin und singe.
Und dann die volle Fläche füllen.
[Musik]
Ja, man könnte jetzt auch eine große Rolle nehmen
und wäre natürlich sofort fertig.
Aber
wer will das schon?
Außerdem habe ich nur so einen kleinen Eimer.
Und ich meditiere dabei.
[Musik]
Die Wand darf jetzt trocknen.
Ich finde die Farbe echt schön.
Finde ich gut.
Und sobald sie getrocknet ist,
ziehe ich das Klebeband ab.
Und dann geht es gleich mit der Wanddeko weiter.
Ei, wie schön!
Josh, das musst du nah aufnehmen.
Das ist so satisfying.
>> JOSH: It's so satisfying.
>> SALLY: It's so satisfying.
Hast du gerade meinen Satisfying Moment
einfach ausgelacht?
>> JOSH: Mh, ein bisschen.
Das war ein kleiner Fail.
>> SALLY: Ein kleiner.
Wir probieren es gleich an anderer Stelle noch mal.
Ah, bitte!
Ich brauche das Malervlies eh nicht mehr.
Den hätte ich jetzt gern hier.
Okay?
[Musik]
Ja.
Sehr gut!
[Musik]
Oh! Mir wird es gleich schwindelig davor.
Hängt es?
Anscheinend.
Juhu!
Das erste Dekoelement hängt!
Wie schön!
[Musik]
Die Ohrringaufbewahrung, die kommt jetzt bei mir hier dran.
Einfach kurz mit einem Nagel.
Das ist ja nicht so schwer.
[Musik]
Ja.
Ist doch süß.
[Musik]
Das ist immer so die
Kunst, das zu treffen.
Beim ersten Mal.
Ich nehme jetzt noch so Filzgleiter hier unten drunter.
So macht ihr euch eure Möbel und Tische nämlich nicht kaputt.
Damit nichts verkratzt und alles schön eben steht.
[Musik]
Ripplinger?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Darf ich?
>> JOSH: Ja, bereit.
>> SALLY: Palik?
>> SARAH: Palik ready.
>> MAX: Wer ist von euch...
>> SALLY: Palik, du musst anmachen.
>> SARAH: Ach so!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Überlegt mal, wie die Ecke hier
vorher ausgesehen hat.
Jetzt ist sie echt schon richtig schön.
Jetzt hole ich einfach den Schmuck,
hänge ihn rein und dann bin ich fertig.
[Musik]
Sarah, du bist ja echt eine professionelle
Samthockerstreichlerin.
>> SARAH: Gelernt ist gelernt.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Oh!
Ich finde das so schön!
Ich glaube, ich komme einfach nur noch hierher
und gucke mir die Ordnung an
und dann geht es mir gut am Abend.
[Musik]
Es war doch mehr Arbeit als gedacht.
Also eigentlich wollte ich ursprünglich
nur die Kettenaufbewahrung machen.
Dann kam der Armreifaufbewahrungsständer dazu,
dann noch die Ohrringe,
dann noch die Idee mit den hängenden Ohrringen.
Okay, und dann kam irgendwie die ganze Nische hier
zustande.
Jedenfalls habe ich es jetzt geschafft, bin fertig.
Und ich finde, was man echt sagen muss,
dass Pflanzen so einen Raum echt cool aufwerten.
Also ich finde so ein bisschen Grün hier
– da oben hänge ich auch noch eine Pflanze hin –
macht das Ganze schon ein bisschen wohnlicher und schöner.
Und jetzt habe ich endlich Platz
für den Schmuck, habe alles schön griffbereit
und vor allem schön aufbewahrt.
Und vielleicht habt ihr euch ja
die eine oder andere Idee auch holen können.
Schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare.
Und schreibt mir auch gerne,
welches Do-It-Yourself ihr als nächstes sehen wollt.
Was wir auf jeden Fall auf unserer To-do-Liste haben,
ist das Baumhaus der Kinder,
also das Spielhaus.
Das wollen wir noch ein bisschen verschönern.
Und da, denke ich, nehmen wir euch auch ganz einfach mit.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
[Musik]